hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and welcome back to my channel
um you know I've been uh looking at some
of the comments uh on some of the recent
videos and uh you know one of the
comments that I got was uh asking about
Euro currency well there's actually a
few comments asking you know does order
flow work in Forex markets it does but
uh honestly you know I'm a Futures guy
I'm not a Forex guy however you know
when I started in the Futures industry I
actually worked on the CME floor back
when there was still the uh
you know the the Deutsche Mark and Swiss
franc this was well before the time of
the Euro right we had the currency
quadrant which was uh I worked in the
spot where we did Dean winter where we
did Deutsche marks and Swiss Francs the
other side of the pit was uh Japan uh
British pound Aussie Dollar Mexican peso
um obviously now that we don't have the
Deutsche Mark anymore it's the euro
currency so there's always been sort of
a fondness in my heart for the
currencies and you know the euro
currency is a great contract to trade
especially using order flow now
you can use a minute based chart or you
could use a range base chart
um you know people history a question
came up
um you know why do I use a minute based
chart because you know honestly that's
the chart most Traders are familiar with
you know people like to get into sort of
uh you know these really refined charts
for a specific Market I just find it's
easier to explain something on a
time-based chart everybody's familiar
with that you know if I start to dig
deeper into say you know a
you know like whatever a 497 tick chart
or whatever something like that you know
not everybody's going to want to use
that but everyone's familiar with a
time-based chart or even a range based
chart now for currencies like I said a
minute based chart is fine
um on the CME Euro currencies I think
you could use an eight range or a 10
range chart but I'm going to start here
with uh a minute based chart now
this is uh kind of a basic footprint
chart right with your
imbalances your point of controls your
Delta at the bottom and
one of the things that I like to use
because you know when I first released
the order flows Trader software
um in 2015
um
you know I was trading Euro currencies
was one of the markets that I was
actively trading and
you know I used a lot of minute-based
charts and as well as eight range charts
and what I found was you know point of
controls play a pretty important part in
my analysis of currencies you know what
is the point of control it's the price
level in the bar with the most volume
right it's really simple nothing fancy
you're just looking at the price level
right a bar will cover several a bunch
of price levels but the one price level
that has the most volume that was traded
on the bid and the offer not in the
two-way auction just at that price level
is going to be your point of control and
this is sort of how the whole concept of
prominent important controls came about
because I found that there were certain
point of controls that mattered more
than others now you'll see
if it's this magenta that's a bearish
Prominent Point of control
now you'll see also here there's uh well
cyan would be a bullish primary reporter
control this is cyan cyan this uh Green
Line this green line this green line is
is what we call a slingshot point of
control this is a another form of point
of control analysis I'm either going to
have bullish ones or bearish ones now on
the order flows Trader software if you
were to go into
uh the settings right you'll find it in
here under POC slingshot right you can
see red and green primary pointed
controls until tested cyan and magenta
use Prominent Point control level one
Prominent Point of control level two
and
basically what I would always look for
in the currencies are these areas of
heavy volume coming in right after ends
of moves right we had to move up here
then you know we made this new high this
this was today uh
let's say Thursday the 17th of August
and we start coming off then we get the
red candle with the heavy volume up near
the top you know light volume inside
these are thin prints obviously the zero
zero one in here
um you know we had this little bit of a
sell-off and on the way down then you
know on the way back up we got another
bullish uh point of control this time
it's a slingshot point of control
followed by another one here another one
here these are Prominent Point of
controls here and here as the market
moved back up and where did we trade
back up to well we trade back up to
where we had this previous Prominent
Point of control that wasn't tested in
the next bar right when I'm looking at
Prominent Point of controls I like them
to be untested in the next bar what does
that mean well for example if this is a
bearish Prominent Point of control it's
met on the point of control basis but
the next bar
um test it right we opened up at uh 109
22 and a half and trade it up to 109 uh
23 and
basically filled the lack of a better
word that Prominent Point of control
when it's unfilled meaning untested it
in my opinion has more strength right
and I have a bunch of followers that
have been trading with me for a long
time that they just they wait for these
Prominent Point of controls or these
slingshot point of controls to appear
and be untested in the next bar and
that's a trade that they they love to
take
and again you know point of controls
primary point of controls especially can
act as support or resistance
in the market right again you know
you'll see our high of the day at this
time right we just made our new high up
here at 109 34 and a half bearish Prime
reported control coming in at 32. Market
sells off where do we rally back up to
well we get up to 32 30
two and a half 33 33 and a half so just
a couple ticks through right and then we
start coming off again you got another
bearish Prominent Point of control one
here but it's tested in the next two
bars another one that's not tested came
back up here to try and test it but
didn't quite
um get into that area so it is left
hanging out there right it's an
abandoned point of control a version
point of control if you will and we sell
off where do we sell off to a point
where we got a bullish Prominent Point
of control
and what's interesting about this
bullish power point of control that's
formed is coming in one tick right above
this earlier
um slingshot point of control it's also
a bullish point of control that's this
green line
um where's it coming in I could be right
here at 17 and a half right it just sort
of jumps up but look at that I mean it
comes right down to the tick you put in
another bullish one and what happens
Market rallies up to where where you had
the previous point of control previous
Prominent Point of control coming in
then you kick off with another bearish
one a point of control on the extreme
right on the edge of the bar and then
the market sells off
okay that's why you know when I talk
about point of controls
um becoming Market generated you know
general you know they're the result of
Market generated information the result
of actual trading that's taking place
why is it important because you know you
have strong passive buying coming in
down here stopping volume if you will
rallies up to where you have selling
volume coming in stopping volume as well
this time it's selling down here was
buying to stop that move okay and you
can see how the Market's just constantly
go back and forth between these levels
right you got it stops here comes back
up you got a bearish one see it comes
down right to that tick
sort of holding these these levels comes
down here makes a new low or you know a
new swing low rallies back up to where
where you had those prominent pointed
controls uh from earlier okay now this
is a
this is a time-based chart
uh Euro currency right again I like to
use eight range
a chart you could also use a 10 range
chart and again I'd be looking for sort
of the exact same things now obviously
things are going to be a bit different
because now this is a range based chart
as opposed to a Time based chart so the
bars are going to be forming different
right bars are going to be moving based
off of price movements you know for lack
of a better way to explain it it's a
range based charge so bars will form as
the range start you know as price starts
moving okay and you can see bullish
primary point of control right down here
right comes right down got this nice
swing low here bullish Prime opponent
control goes up working our way back up
a bullish power point of control and
then one here as you're making new highs
now you don't have the bearish pound
point of control up here at 32 that you
had on the minute base chart
because the bars are constructed
differently got a bearish modern point
of control here but it's been tested in
the next bar you got one here okay
barely tested it in this bar but came
right back up and
tested it and sort of invalidated it
there
one here one here so again you know if
you're taking these shorts like maybe
you're getting short off this you get
stopped out fine just wait for the next
trade next trade comes in right and you
know so you know you lose here
you lose here on this trying to get
short off of this
Prominent Point of control but again
where would you be getting short in this
case all right you have the bearish
primary point of control forming in this
bar
but
you waiting for this next bar to
complete it's not that you just have a
bearish pound reported control you
immediately get long or short or get
short rather it's a bearish pound point
of control
you got to wait till this bar closes
although you know it's a range based
chart it's going to get within one tick
of it and okay it doesn't test it maybe
you want to wait until well you do want
to wait till the next bar forms but
maybe you want to wait a little bit see
if it's going to test it right off the
open or not
um like you did in this bar but
if you're getting short you're getting
short you know somewhere around the
close of this bar here
right with the stop just above that high
just as here you're getting short off of
um
this candle here right because you got
to wait for this bar to close you know
and your stops just right above it so
it's not like you're getting short in in
these two cases way down here
okay or maybe you know you want to wait
for the Prominent Point of control to
appear then the next bar to be red right
as opposed to a green bar that's working
its way back up like this is a green bar
this is a green bar there's a red bar
okay now you could get short or look for
Oh either it gets short immediately once
this red bar closes or you know look for
a little bit of a pullback and get short
I'm not saying it's going to pull all
the way back up here
but you know you got to be ready for
those to catch these trades so even if
you got stopped out here you know maybe
you lost five picks up here you lost
five ticks
you know you're talking a move from I
mean you could realistically have gotten
short right on the open of this bar at
uh oh one and a half
then it just you know quickly you know
this is 1005 you know over the next
um 30 minutes trades all the way down
from you know what is that oh one one
and a half all the way straight down I
mean there's no red bars or sorry no
green bar up here this is your first
green bar right here you know down to
87.
right now this Market trades in half
tick so that's like
the set but close to 30 ticks then you
get another bearish pound point of
control right here a similar thing right
now in this case it started to go down
sort of came back up worked its way back
up
doesn't quite stop you out here but then
you got a nice bullish Prominent Point
of control
that you could take advantage of
here and the next bar comes within one
tick of that okay then it closes up here
it adds your sign to get long and it
moves back up again we have this bearish
Prime opponent of control right up here
at 08 and a half doesn't quite get there
it gets up to five before it works its
way back down okay so you know that's
the whole idea of trading around
prominent pointed controls now
um just really quick
that is on
ninjatrader okay now if you are into
let's see into Forex but go charting
okay
go charting is a web-based platform that
my indicators are are now on
you can actually uh use you know all the
workflows tools on there but if you're
going to be trading 4X I would
recommend go charting as your platform
for charting as opposed to the
ninjatrader platform one it's it's
actually
um a bit cheaper but
ninjatrader is more geared towards
Futures Traders okay whereas go charting
is more of a general training platform
and again you know if you're looking at
Prominent Point controls the nice thing
about
um
no charting
is you can sort of scrunch up your
charts and you can see these areas where
there's the prominent important control
coming in here I'd have to
clean this up a little bit just so
you're not confused by a lot of these
other lines here just give me a second I
will turn off
extension and
uh one other thing in here
I got problem important controls on I'm
going to turn off the thin prints so the
nice thing is if you're just using a
simple bar chart right you can see
bullish Prime opponent control bullish
Prominent Point of control
bearish Prominent Point of control
bearish Prominent Point of control right
that is not tested in the next bar right
and
you know another bullish one down here
right you could just you know that's on
a one minute chart you know you want to
use a five minute chart to see if
there's anything in there sometimes
there is I I prefer to trade you know
here's a bullish power point of control
on the five minute chart
um
if there's anything else on the five
minute chart but again it's something
you could take a look at even you know
the nice thing about go charting is you
can get all the uh
you get all the pairs you get it's from
the data it's from Rwanda so you know
maybe you want I don't know Euro uh Euro
Japan Euro versus the end
um yeah that's a five minute chart you
know if you trade in on the short term
right
see in here
nice bullish primary point of control
here on the way up
um you know it was a bearish one down
here not tested and you know there's a
bearish one here you see the market came
right back to that level literally
and
came off again
um here it got within one tick this is
the Euro versus the Yen
um you see you get all the all these
pairs I mean I don't know what to look
at uh
gosh you know Singapore dollar
uh
get the Hound
Hound versus Singapore I don't know what
this looks like
honestly so I don't know if there's
gonna be anything in here worth trading
but you know here's a bearish one here
again this is on a one minute chart
um you know bearish one there
Irish one there so there's there's some
moves to be had right
here here here
you know on the way up so again
um if you're going to be trading uh 4X I
suggest the go charting platform
um and again right now you can get the
order flows Trader software for free
until the end of this month if you want
to play around with the Prominent Point
of controls and their their importance
in
um markets all right everyone thanks and
I'll catch you guys on the next video
bye-bye